hello there welcome once again to
Android design in action I'm your host
Roman Nurik hey guys it's Adam Kashia
and over in London we have so today we
have a special episode dedicated
entirely to the action bar design
pattern we unfortunately don't have any
redesigns to do today or kind of you
know we're not going to look at any
specific apps but we will talk in depth
about the action bar so with that I
guess we should just jump right in
because we have a lot of content to go
through Adam do you wanna kick things
off yeah sure so one quick thing before
we get started
Nick may potentially be coming through
on one audio channel only so if you've
got one ear but in here maybe switch the
other one if you can't hear it in case
you can't hear in case UK potentially is
yes so let's get started we wanted to do
a deep dive on the action bar today so
the action bar had a couple of quotes
here from the design guide so I'm just
gonna quickly read them out the action
bar is a dedicated piece of real estate
at the top of each screen that is
generally persistent throughout the app
and the second quote which actually
liked better the action bar is one of
the most important design elements you
can implement and will go a long way
toward making your apps interface
consistent with the core Android apps so
I think you know people ask why should i
implement the action bar I'd rather go
off and do some other design pattern I
think consistency is just really really
important so that when users pick up
your application they instantly kind of
know how to use it because they're so
used to the system apps so it's just a
really really important design pattern
if you've been listening to a show and
hopefully you've been looking at the
design side hopefully you already notice
yeah and the action bar through all of
the designs that we've done ourselves
we've always included an action bar
there some cases where you know an
action bar it may not be necessarily for
example Google now does not actually
have an action bar and it's top level
screen but if you notice you once you
get into the detail screens once you get
it's like the settings screen or or
things like that there is an action bar
so there's some kind of edge cases where
you may not need one but almost
certainly 99%
we should include our you know I
consider it's one of those cases of
deviate with purpose like and this is a
really good reason you probably want to
be using one definitely alright let's
move along here so the general
organization again hopefully you're
familiar with this already but we just
sort of thought we'd cover it again the
basics so on the left portion of the
action bar you know you have your
navigational elements and then on the
right side the action so it's pretty
clearly split between the two sides I
think that's it's a very important
pattern to follow this this sort of
general layout if you do sort of decide
to deviate in some way shape or form you
should just always keep this in mind and
try and stick to this if you possibly
can
yeah and actually one minor comment is I
think in earlier versions of honeycomb
the search button in some apps was
actually on the left and then we moved
that over to the right as an action
because that was really just a more
common place and we really wanted to
standardize as search being an action
rather than a navigational element it
can be portrayed to me if you think
about it logically you can you can
probably argue either way for search but
certainly the platform convention is to
keep it as an action so we've got a bit
more detail here around the general
organization of the action bar a very
very important piece the app icons so
here you've sort of got your branding
their identity and also it gives you
sort of sense of place with this sort of
up affordance that shows when you're at
the not at the top level screens so
personally I think people should always
take advantage of the branding piece of
this not only because it sort of tells
the user which application they're in
when they're using it but also you know
if they love the app they're going to
start to identify that that branding
with your application next time they're
flicking through their home screen on
there there's sort of all apps list
they'll see that icon there there hey I
haven't used app that happened a while
and I really really like it up and
they'll come back to it so I think it's
just really important sometimes I see
people do custom implementations or a
custom kind of action bar but they don't
include that branding personally I feel
very strongly that it's important
a variation on that I'd like to just
mention here is it quite commonly an
application might have a single accent
color which you strongly associate with
that brand so you know dribble all might
be pain for example and so forth and so
there's also the opportunity to take the
accent color as your action bar color
altogether and in that case I think it
works really really nicely to have a
differentiated logo from icon so it's
entirely plausible and absolutely
encouraged to have a different like
launcher icon that you might have in the
launch tray then the icon that which
appears in the and the top left of the
action bar you might go for inverted
color or maybe you know a single white
and you know simplified version of your
icon and then use the branding color in
as the actual background of the action
bar rather than having it compete for
the same color as long as long as the
core icon itself is the same as long as
the the shapes and the forms are really
kind of the same thing as the launcher
icon you can you can definitely do that
and of course the the YouTube app kind
of does this with it's a it's launcher
icon being different to the to the
action bar app icon up there yeah and
actually the the I think they use a logo
as well so you don't necessarily have to
use an icon there if you have enough
horizontal space available where you
don't need other items like view
controls you can absolutely show a wider
version that for developers that's
called the Android colon logo for the
action bar but both the icon and the
logo those should be sufficient to
convey the brand name now that works
pretty well so if you have one natural
homepage like a newsfeed of thing which
is the natural home of the content you
might want to provide greater branding
let's say a larger logo which takes up
more width and on subsequent pages you
might want to collapse that back down to
say a square aspect ratio icon which
will give you more room to display some
kind of title information or you can
draw exactly and that segues perfectly
into the second part of the action bar
which is the view control you know it
can be used for navigation something
like a spinner but also as as Nick
mentioned it can be used for sort of a
title of the particular screen as well
the view control also encompasses tabs
so in some cases especially on phones
and we'll talk about this in a bit but
tabs can go in that area but in some
cases they actually drop into a second
lower area below that action bar is a
stacked version but tab spinner and
titles we can we consider those kind of
view controls things that let you see
information about the current context
the current screen as well as
potentially kind of tweak things like
you know change the the sorting or
arrest necessary sorting change the the
perspective or like the label or
something that you're looking at go and
then as we mention on the right side
you've got your actions so you've got
the action buttons there in this case
there's a search and a record video
action followed by what we call the
action overflow menu so this is where
less frequently use actions can be
collapsed into an overflow menu that's
not always visible on the screen and
there very importantly for the overflow
there are also some platform conventions
on what things should always go there so
if you have application settings as well
as help and about Terms of Service
things like that should go in the
overflow you shouldn't make those
immediately on screen unless something
like settings is like the number one use
case for your app like if everybody is
just tweaking the settings but in almost
like I'd say again a 10% of cases
overflow should contain settings as well
all right moving along it's a web
meeting about the Oakland I'm sorry just
before you do me very girlfriend we're
talking about the case of devices which
have a physical menu button then the
overflow button won't necessarily
display because it's so you're gonna
rely on that physical affordance rather
than the on-screen affordance yep good
point and I think we have a screen shot
later on to to sort of show how that
works no worries so the other nice thing
about the action bar is it's it's very
good at adapting to different screen
sizes rotations actually the width of
the screen it's very very good at
adapting that so it does a few things to
help with the variation in screen sizes
and actually I think it's the next slide
one particular thing that you can do is
is engage this mode called split action
bar mode and actually from a developer
standpoint it's a it's it's a flag
called split action bar when narrow so
it sort of says when the screen width
gets down to a certain point we're going
to go into this split action bar mode
instead so in split action bar mode
you've sort of got three potential
different bars that you can have here
you've got the main action bar at the
top you've got the top bar which Roman
was talking about before is where the
tabs could potentially fall down to and
then at the bottom of the screen you've
got the bottom bar very creatively named
here at the bottom bar top bar and
you'll see that at the bottom bar in the
bottom bar you've got the action items
which have now moved down there along
with trailing off into the overflow menu
rather than being at the top right there
within the main action bar and a couple
more points on on this screen you'll
notice that the the concept of like
navigation versus action the separation
of the two is still in play except that
spatially it's no longer horizontal it's
purely vertical at the top you have all
of your navigational affordances and
elements and at the very bottom you have
your actions so that that a pattern is
still kept in check the the other thing
I wanted to mention was actually on the
previous screen not only is the is the
scalability like the the stretchiness of
the action bar important on different
devices but you'll also notice that on
on tablets the action bar is actually
slightly taller the app icon is
displayed slightly larger and the action
bar buttons are slightly wider so an
action bar button on a phone maybe
something like 56 dips wide
how about I think it's about 64 dips and
then the action bar height I think it's
something like 48 and then on tablets
it's 56 or something like that
but again this stuff changes you know
this stuff may change so I'm just using
the standard action bar it gives you all
of this for free yeah and if potentially
some huge tablet comes out in the future
or something like that you know the
action bar may have a different size
again a different way of formatting but
as long as you stick to using the action
bar your applications should still sort
of look and display fine here mom all
right yep
context to action bar Nick you want to
you want to discuss that a little bit
yeah definitely so the conditional
action bar is one of my favorite tricks
and so it has the ability to track
transform its appearance to give you
contextual actions to level what's on
screen so in this screenshot here we can
see examples of select some text or
selecting an email message and where the
same physical spec it's kind of like
animates and rotates around and offers
alternate alternate actions and the
contextual action bar really is a
first-class citizen like the like the
standard action bar and you can still do
things like the split action bar so you
know if you have a plethora of options
that you want to have immediately
available on-screen without having to
dip down into the overflow you can go
into that split mode like the mail app
is there and show you those things
immediately and if you want to know more
about contextual action well we actually
did a deep dive on this a couple of
couple of months back so you can go back
through the archives into the video
messaging that come up yeah and it's
worth knowing that generally it's
engaged by long-pressing on a particular
element of the screen so in this example
I think we have browser and then Gmail
email in some cases though there can be
a UI element that you could touch upon
to engage it so in this case in Gmail
it's a it's a checkbox that you could
touch that checkbox and the contextual
action bar triggers at that point the
other important thing to note about
contextual action bars is that
conceptually and just logically they're
they're a mode right so when you select
something you're basically entering into
a UI mode and that mode is you know
something is selected so what happens is
you know the the context of the screen
you know the the layout of the screen
doesn't really change like for example
in Gmail's case the list items are still
there but the action bar basically kind
of like that
chrome around the content changes to
reflect what mode you're in and then
once you kind of cancel out of that mode
by either pressing the back button or
pressing the the check mark and in the
top left that and that cancels the mode
that exits the mode and then you're back
to kind of what the screen normally was
so just think of it as a UI mode almost
so moving on to the second portion of
the action bar that were talking about
the view controls so one possible option
to show there in the view control
section are tabs and there's sort of two
main categories of tabs there's fixed
tabs and scrollable tabs and there's a
couple of examples there on the slides
that you can see I personally really
like fixed tabs you know where they're
appropriate just because it's really
really quick and easy to flip between
the different views obviously they're
only appropriate when you've got maybe
two three maybe four items
sorry different views that you want to
flip between and obviously you should
always enable swipe to navigate between
those different tabs then you've also
got scrollable tabs where you could
potentially have any number of different
views that you're switching between it
could be a known number but larger
number than say the four three or four
that fixed tab support or it could be an
unknown number that you don't know how
many sort of gonna trail off there so
here's an example from a Play Store yeah
so one thing to note is that if you're a
developer and you're trying to implement
this it's actually called a pager title
strip it's a little kind of a misnomer
we call them scrollable tabs in the
design side because logically and from
from a kind of a mental model
perspective they they serve the same
purpose as tabs it's just like from an
interaction standpoint they're slightly
different so one of the key differences
is that you know you don't see them all
at once and they're slightly thinner so
they're not really a touch target
they're really more an indicator but
usually they're they are coupled with
touch so in case the user touch does
touch that area you know that indicates
the next page is a previous page you
should still kind of swipe over or
switch over yeah and in terms of how it
fits in with the action bar you know in
that split action bar mode these fixed
tabs will actually take up the whole
width below the main action bar and so
all the scroll tabs but when there's
more room for example in a lance
mode or on a tablet those fixed tabs can
actually fall in line with the main
action bar whereas the scrollable tabs
really need to take up the entire width
of the screen and then another option
when we're talking about the different
bars you can have so you can have your
main action bar your top bar and a
bottom bar it's in some cases having a
top action bar as well as the the
stacked tab bar doesn't add anything so
it's entirely valid to hide the top
action but it's not really add anything
to your design and you want to free up
some more content area of your apps if
you take a look at for example at the
dialer application or contacts
applications and that ship with ICS the
personal devices you can see there
they've hidden the top action managers
have the free fixed tabs right at the
top to free up some room another example
of that from the third-party space is a
Pinterest and I wouldn't say that they
exactly use tabs I mean they look and
feel like tabs you know you can swipe
between them and there's you know there
are three of them so they kind of
represent tab they're very similar to
like you know the People app tabs or
such that's another example so there's
an example of where you know the the
widths aren't equal you know the thus
the Home tab on the pincher and the
Pinterest app is default selected so
it's it's a slight variation but again
it's a deviation with a purpose they
wanted to simplify things I think that
it's a it's a fairly good execution
so moving on view controls you can also
have spinners and drawers I don't think
we're gonna spend too long in here
because we know there's a lot of
discussion about drawer still and the
the patterns still not finalized on the
design side but just to quickly mention
it
both of them are sort of ways to switch
between views a spinner is a drop-down
pop-up kind of dialog that that's that
drops down from the top of the action
bar which allows you to switch between
views the navigation drawer slides out
from the side and the YouTube app is
sort of the main example of how to
implement a navigation drawer at this
point in time I don't know if you guys
want to mention anything more about this
we could probably talk about drawers
versus spinners for much longer than a
half note at a high level I'd say just
you know looking at the different
options you know tabs spinner navigation
jar when you look at these elements I
mean they're very they're functionally
somewhat equivalent there are some minor
differences in in terms of when you
should use a spinner versus navigation
drawer as well as you know when it's
appropriate to use tabs versus spinner
but you know functionally they're their
lateral navigation element so they let
you navigate across sibling elements or
sibling screens and then you know it's
kind of interesting to look at the
action bars navigational components as
both ancestral navigation and lateral
navigation so the UP button which which
we made brief mention of lets you
accomplish ancestral navigation lets you
walk up the structure of an app versus
you know tabs or spinners navigation
drawers they let you navigate laterally
across the structure of your app so when
you're when you're planning out you know
how do how do you design an app that
uses you know all these different
navigational elements think about your
your app in terms of a screen map or
think about it in terms of you know a
structure a tree almost a hierarchical
structure and see where you can
introduce elements to better convey that
structure to your users yeah one thing I
will quickly say is it a very much
dislike it when a drawer has three items
in it because it could much eat much
much better be represented by something
like like regular tabs and you know it
gives the user the on-screen visuals
immediately there I can swipe it to them
it's just so much easier so yeah it's
one pet peeves but one of the other
things since we're on the topic of that
we're gonna get stuck on this important
one of the things that's different
between Android and other platforms is
tabs aren't persistent so this is one
thing that I have seen you know some
folks get caught up caught up with they
keep tabs visible throughout the entire
app so the action bar is really you know
the one thing that should really be
present throughout the entire app
because it gives you access to the UP
button as well as things like settings
and whatnot but tabs are really a per
screen type thing so if your top level
screen has tabs once you get into a
detail screen from within one of those
tabs like let's say you touch a list
item in tab one you should hide those
tabs and then to get back to those tabs
users should press up to get to the the
top level screen that has those tabs so
that's one thing to make sure that you
don't do is have hierarchy and and
history within a tab the tab is really
just like a segment of the screen almost
yeah yeah action bar is the anchor of
the application it should be visible all
the time and the other element should
sort of come and go as needed yeah all
right let's let's get on can't get away
from this before we get action buttons
neat you know yeah so action button is
at the right hand section of the the
action bar which allow you to perform
actions which are contextual to the
content on screen we kind of use this
fit rule which you can see on screen
here to determine which actions should
appear like front and center right on
the action bar and which ones are less
important and should be like tucked away
under the overflow menu so the fit
scheme it refers to something which is
frequently important or typical so if
you know just some examples that
frequently if you in an image
application image viewing application
like the gallery for example you
frequently want to share that so we have
the share action button right front and
center in the action bar so it's very
easy to do that a cheaper and something
which is important say in an email
application we have the send button in
the action bar it's right there at the
top of screen as the most important
thing and one more thing is one single
like very the most important action on
the screen try and keep it to the left
most action because that's more likely
to be shown on
the action bar and not tucked away under
the overflow if there is an exhibition
room and last the rules is typical so
something like searches we touched on
slightly earlier on you're gonna always
look to the top right to look for the
search action because it's typically
found there so you wouldn't want to
follow that rule and one one thing I
just like to kind of clarifying that is
there we've caught out at the bottom
here saying that items in the action bar
needs to be unambiguous as to what
they're going to apply to so if there's
something like an edit action in the
action mark but there's actually a
couple of distinct groups of content on
the screen and so it's unclear and you
want to basically put that action inline
in the content area so there's no
ambiguity you want to either do that
inline or you can perhaps is the context
action bar in that instance to enable
some kind of some most then perform the
action on an individual piece of content
and the other thing we wanted to call
out here is to really try and like we
use people's mental models for these
these comments these very
well-established actions are surfing
like search or edit or share has these
very well-known kind of lists associated
with these actions so you want to be
using the platform default one so take a
look at the there's a download on the
design side of the action bar download
pack as well as the brilliant asset
studio which will help you to kind of
you find or kind of slightly hint these
and my constituency the other very minor
thing on that is that don't feel you
know that you're restricted to use the
styling you know holo dark or holo light
styling for the action bar buttons if
you have a very very branded you know
action bar or very brand that happened
general that has you know its own color
scheme maybe even some you know some
minor visual effects here and there just
as long as you use the core iconography
and the core iconography you can get
with the illustrator files that come
with that download just apply your
styling on top of those illustrator
files so that you still use the same
iconography not necessarily the same
style
yeah and one last thing I just want to
mention was don't feel like you have to
put actions necessarily in the action
well you can't put them in line as well
like that's definitely an alternate
option if it's relevant to the content
or it sort of fits better with the flow
of the screen you could possibly put
something in line you know it's
definitely not our option but you know
if that's not what you want if you want
to stick to this sort of standard
pattern put them in the action bar all
right so we've touched on this earlier
on as well about the you're not actually
saying this item you must must must sure
I think the whole point of the action
bar is it really helps you to build on
this responsive design technique that we
were always talking about you know
Android is designed Android is designed
to scale and you don't necessarily know
at design time how wide the eye that the
device is going to be which your app is
running on you know is it in landscape
there's been portrait is it like a
tablet size device and so the action bar
is really built with that in its
underpinnings and so the way you define
your actions you actually you can say if
you should always show up in the action
bar and never kind of go under under the
overflow menu if it should or conversely
never so something like settings you
would say never show this as a front and
center action papasan the overflow and
the last one the most interesting once
you probably want to use for most of
your actions is just to say if room so
what they will say is that if there's
room please display this and I've always
tuck it under and the system will go
through in the order of which you've
defined your actions and and kind of try
to show as many as it can and then any
it doesn't have room for get tucked
under the overflow and so it really kind
of you want to be thinking about your
actions and say you know something like
an email application send should always
be on the screen but these other things
are less important and they can they can
go underneath a and their flow need be
and so don't get hung up on thinking
these two things are always going to be
on the screen these things are always
going to be off screen try and work with
the if room and try and like have this
kind of stretchable design as you can I
really like this because it forces you
to think about the fit pattern that we
were talking about before and just
really prioritize which acts and actions
you think are most important you know
for user has the Nexus S and they can
only fit two items up there then as long
you were always going to have the two
you know
items that you think we're most
importantly visible to you to the user
so I think I think it's a good way of
decluttering your UI almost like it sort
of forces you to tackle that problem
rather than just say how throw
everything on the screen I hope the user
can work out what's happening all right
we better get moving here guys yeah so
I'll just quickly jump through the key
styles for branding so you've seen this
through our various you know designs
throughout this show but the key things
that you should think about when styling
the action bar and outside of adjusting
a picking color schemes you can
obviously also apply you know patterns
or subtle gradients and and yes just
solid colors to these you should really
be thinking about the action bars core
background that's a kind of the number
one way you can brand things you know if
you're if you're Yahoo which probably be
purple or something like that for the
stacked bar background you probably want
to use a very similar a similar shade or
a similar hue but a slightly darker or
slightly lighter version the reason you
don't want to do something too crazy is
that again in landscape your tabs can
actually stack up into the top bar and
so the tabs may not have enough contrast
if there's a completely different color
pallet between action bar background and
it's stacked background you can probably
make it work through some tricks here
and there but it's generally easiest if
you if you just make a slight variation
to the background first act the stacked
top bar also the selected tab strip
that's where you can really kind of show
your your brand's accent color if you
have a secondary a secondary color in
your palette as well as the press state
background so that's Duffy something to
keep in mind if you're if your action
bar background is blue the default press
state background for the action bar is
also going to be blue you know if you
touch an icon or if you touch the UP
button it's gonna be blue background so
the contrast may not be very good so
make sure to tweak that and keep into
account for that
an article in the Android developers
blog enhancer cheesie's gonna styling
Denis
what was it Jayden MP slash like
customizing action bar I think you just
search for Nick butcher customizing the
action bar you okay yeah I forget all
right and then there's the there's the
really awesome action bar style
generator tool for developers that you
can basically just create all the assets
you need right from this tool really
awesome tool we use it in a lot of our
samples there's an additional style
called action about overlay style that
you can use if say the content is just
so important in this particular screen I
can really make the action buttons of
system chrome fade out a little bit here
so there's two examples here one is
Google Maps on the right there and you
can see you know the map is obviously
just the most important thing within an
application like Google Maps and so you
can see it's transparent allowing the
map to sort of bleed through a little
bit there it looks really really nice
and then the system gallery is another
great example which were using right now
and one thing you should do is if you
know it's something like gallery where
where the user may want to see the
picture without any other sort of chrome
visible
you know touching the screen should
really make the action bar come on
screen and then disappear again along
with the system this status bar and
potentially the status bar as well and
the system controls down the bottom it's
not really possible with something like
photo viewing but with video viewing can
actually make you know make the entire
thing go fullscreen and there's that for
developers out there there's a template
that you could use with eclipse if you
do file new and then Android object you
can choose full screen activity and it
gives you all this for free okay we got
to be able oh yes got some customer
action views Nick you want to take us a
very quick oh yeah sure so you got five
words just have to be just buttons they
can be a little bit more interactive and
responsive than that so here's a few
examples of the stock one so you have a
common pattern SD transform a refreshed
icon into an indeterminate progress
spinner so you can using the same space
indicate progress or an action which is
great and and
when is the search action provider so
this is a way to when you click on the
search action have it expand out it's
kind of like take over the action bars
physical space similar to how the
contextual action bar will in order to
provide the other search affordance
which is a great great little pun and
the last one we caught out here is the
share action provider is this is an
excellent way of providing a ordered
list of the way some what to share so if
I always go to you know surfing a couple
of app select you float to the top of
the list and in fact the most commonly
used app to share that certain media
type will be write persistent in the
action bar so it's very easy so you can
have this richer behavior from the
action buttons not just simple buttons
cool excellent
and then I think Nick was talking about
this briefly before but some devices
still have a hard menu button and so in
that case the overflow menu actually
doesn't show in the action bar and
instead when you hit the device hard
menu or legacy menu button the
additional overflow items will pop up
from the bottom so you can see that here
on the Nexus S versus the Nexus 4 where
the overflow menu still pops up those
same options not gonna think we just
done this guy doing and lastly right and
lastly done in this card this is
something that's not yet documented I
think we'll probably be documenting in
the future but as an alternative if you
have if you have a really really simple
screen like for example you know like
just a single screen edit or a single
edit screen or something and you really
only have two things you can do right
you can either save or a cancel and you
don't want to use a dialog because you
know generally you want to avoid dialogs
you want to avoid the extra you know
burden on the user to think about what's
what else is around the screen you can
you can use the done slash discard
pattern we're basically instead of an
action bar instead of the UP button
instead of kind of a title and overflow
you just show two actions done in this
card and there's again positive button
on the right negative button on the left
alternatively if discarding is not
really that common or if you have other
actions you need to show you can just
show
in the top left which takes the place of
the UP button and that's kind of like
the same thing as saying if I press this
I know I have the added confidence that
when I you know go up or when I leave
this context I'm actually persisting my
my content might changes so that's just
an alternative that you can use for very
simple screens cool and then design news
we could have to fly through it through
it this is from the developer of I think
it was a carbon for Android he had a
bunch of thoughts on holo and you know
what it means what is the language you
know how as a designer are you using it
or are you you know
elaborating on it so just a couple of
thoughts here as a Google+ post
definitely worth reading if you're if
you're designing for Android and lastly
here is a regular contributor Marie
Weitz has given a great like walkthrough
of her mental processes she goes through
the workflow she goes through when she's
designing an application so it's you
know you don't dive straight into your
you know pixel editing tool of choice
but she can't walk through the concept
team behind it and thinking about the
information hierarchy and I really this
Plex was really really great and it's a
good insight into how other people work
cool and we're done yeah with that
thanks again for joining us here on
Android design in action where we talked
about the action bar everything you
needed to know as always I'm Roman Nurik
Adam Kosh you put you see you guys see
ya next week or whatever see you guys
fight